[Musik]
zum tagesgespräch bei phoenix begrüße
ich ganz herzlich guido zöllick dem
präsident der dehoga grüße sie guten tag
herr kohle machen sie demnächst ihr
hotel auch für geimpfte vielleicht für
rentner gruppen also so einfach ist es
leider nicht denn unterstrich brauchen
wir natürlich auch gewissheit dass die
menschen die sich haben impfen lassen
wollen auch die chance dazu hatten
und ich glaube das ist einer der ganz
entscheidenden punkte und das 3 1
entscheidendes kriterium zunächst einmal
muss die impfstrategie greifen es müssen
viele menschen geimpft werden und das
sollte unser oberstes ziel sein dann
können wir uns gedanken darum machen wen
können wir waren in welcher form zur
veranstaltung oder in hotels hast es
gibt ja so eine grundbedingung der
überschrift untersteht wenn impfstoff
für alle da ist das ist natürlich klar
es geht nicht um nächste woche aber
jetzt ist die frage
da wird über privilegien für geimpfte
gesprochen aber auch für strafen für
diejenigen die noch nicht geimpft sind
oder die sich gar nicht impfen lassen
wollen
denken sie schon in ihrem verband für
hotels für gaststätten für bars und auch
für veranstaltungsbereiche darüber nach
da eventuell ein bisschen nach zu
steuern und zu sagen wir müssen aber
auch irgendwie überleben
es wird den unternehmen freigestellt
inwieweit sie als so eine gästegruppen
in ihre unternehmung lassen oder nicht
lassen vorausgesetzt wie gesagt dass
alle die gleiche chance hatten eine
impfung zu bekommen und dann sehe ich es
schon so dass auch unsere unternehmer
entsprechend reagieren werden und
gegebenenfalls ihm nicht geimpfte gäste
mit anderen voraussetzungen oder mit
anderen auflagen rein lassen oder eben
auch gar nicht den zutritt gewähren also
das heißt sie sagen so pauschal darüber
das hausrecht und das veranstalter recht
steht da über allem
es gab aber auch zeiten haben sie von
der dehoga gesagt bitte schließen bitte
zu machen wir müssen jetzt alle
irgendwie in den lock down und die
hotels dürfen kein mehr aufnehmen jetzt
gibt es ja diese sonderregelung schon
für dienstreisen also nicht für
privatreisen nicht für urlaub die hotels
beispielsweise offen zu lassen
wie ist das denn dann
wenn jemand hausrecht gebraucht oder
veranstalter recht aber wie ist es dann
mit kindern
die werden also das ist ja wieder die
eingangsfrage zunächst einmal muss
sichergestellt sein dass jeder eine
impfung bekommen konnte wenn er dann in
unsere betriebe wieder zurückkehren
möchte oder wenn die betriebe daraus
eine auflage machen und an dem punkt
sind wir noch lange nicht also insofern
ist das heute noch nicht das thema aber
in zukunft gerichtet wird es ihn schon
so sein dass diejenigen die eine impfung
vollzogen haben dass die eben auch dann
wieder in unsere betriebe kommen können
ohne andere auflagen zu erfüllen zum
beispiel test die man vorneweg vornehmen
kann
was sind ja maßnahmen die wir jetzt auch
im vorfeld schon propagieren würde sagen
das gehört zu einem geordneten restart
dazu nicht nur unsere konzept in den
häusern sondern eben auch möglicherweise
test die wir mit den gästen gemeinsam
vor ort durchführen und sicherzustellen
dass keine ansteckung in den betrieben
erfolglos reden nämlich alle nur über
impfungen derzeit über tests redet kaum
noch jemand gut dass jetzt erwähnen aber
ich hatte gerade auch gefragt nach
kindern wie ist das es sind ja die
impfstoffe nicht für kinder zugelassen
bisher jedenfalls nicht machen sie es
davon auch abhängig nein also mit den
kindern ist das in unseren betrieben je
eine sache wo in aller regel ja nicht
alleine kommen sondern mit ihren eltern
mit ihren großeltern und irgendeine frau
betriebe dann auf suchen
häufig sind sie alt genug wenn sie
allein in die schule gehen können
sozusagen unsere betriebe eingelassen
da werden wir uns an die gleichen rechte
und pflichten halten die wir der
öffentlichkeit auch also sie sprechen
jetzt nun für einen bereich für hotel
gastronomie es gibt ja auch die anderen
wie konzerte fußballspiele
veranstaltungen reisen und und und da
warten sehr viele auf ja zum beispiel
heute auf den ethikrat was der sagt was
erwarten sie vom ethikrat gibt der hilfe
an die hand oder nicht also das lässt
sich schwer beurteilen denn glaube nicht
dass der ethikrat sich dafür aussprechen
wird
eine gruppe zu isolieren oder
privilegien wie wir das
dafür dürfte tatsächlich jetzt in
relativ kurzer zeit schon umzusetzen
insofern wäre uns viel viel lieber und
wichtiger dass wir rechtlich sicherheit
in die ganze situation gekommen denn
unabhängig davon ob unsere betriebe dann
die fünfte person schneller aufnehmen
können oder nicht steht ja die frage wie
wollen wir denn das kontrollieren und
dürfen wir das überhaupt
denn ich bin nicht der meinung dass
unser budget ist astrologen oder
veranstalter die irgendwas weise sich
einfach zeigen lassen dürfen wir sind
keine behörde die dazu entsprechende
rechte besitzt und das muss man im
vorfeld das taktieren
wir wollen das gespräch gar nicht zu
ende gehen lassen ohne dass ich frage
wie geht das ihre branche was hören sie
derzeit also das ist eine katastrophale
situation denn wir machen jetzt schon
den fünften monat keine umsatz mehr wenn
man den ersten doch damit dazu zählt in
den sommermonaten ist für viele betriebe
überhaupt keine auskömmliche ist
wirtschaften gewesen insofern wir laufen
sozusagen auf dem zahnfleisch
es ist gut dass staatliche hilfen wir
jetzt nach und nach an kommen das hat
lange lange gedauert viel zu lange
gedauert aber jetzt scheint es in die
richtige richtung zu gehen
und ansonsten hoffen wir sehr dass es
möglichst bald wieder losgeht und unsere
betriebe wieder öffnen können weil das
ist das was neben dem finanziellen
genauso auf uns lastet die psychische
anspannung wir wollen arbeiten wir
wollen bei unseren gästen sein können
und so umsetzten selbst erwirtschaften
nicht abhängig von irgendwelchen
staatlichen hilfe wenn diese hoffnung
sind wir auf jeden fall vereint
dankeschön guido zöllick präsident der
dehoga danke fürs gespräch
vielen dank